Beyonce and her family give us yet
another reason to feel proud family
[Music]
yeah scream is exactly what we did when
B posted this photo of the Carter's
Halloween costumes characters from the
2001 Disney Channel animated series The
Proud Family
Queen B and her hubby Jay-Z got into
formation with their three kiddos to
show off their costumes on Instagram
which were so spot on I'm proud of it
the singer pulled double duty dressing
as both mom Trudy Parker proud and
Grandma sugar mama
turn that back on I was watching it yes
sugar mama
Jay-Z takes on the role of dad Oscar
proud while twins roomy and Sir imitated
a bit of real life in costume as the
show's Troublesome twins Cece and BB
no you can't go with Daddy when I get
back I take you fishing in the sink
then there's Blue Ivy totally embracing
main character energy as eldest sister
Penny Proud wearing the signature
pigtails cardigan and collared shirt
good morning parents mother you're
looking especially beautiful today
oh I thank you and Daddy you wearing
that suit move over Denzel Denzel for
the caption the mom of three borrowed
from the series infectious theme song
family every single day and night you
and me will always be quiet
[Music]
those voices yeah you know em it's B and
her former Destiny's Child bandmates
Kelly Rowland and Michelle Williams
plus the special edition of Bee's
younger sister Solange okay whenever
y'all are ready
family
only
[Music]
[Music]
and making it a true Family Affair B's
Mom Tina Knowles Lawson she shared the
snapshot too writing in her caption I
always wanted to see them as the proud
family I love it oh and get this queen
bee's own company Parkwood entertainment
used her photo to troll the delay in
getting visuals for her latest album
Renaissance
yeah hopefully we won't have to wait
till we're Sugar Mama's age for B to
drop some music videos don't start with
me bougie till then we'll be over here
thanking me for this visual with the
whole family
foreign